How do I create a thriving environment
for my team?
Well, it's obvious
we have plants everywhere.
As you can see, this
plant conducts photosynthesis
and provides
lots of oxygen for the environment.
We have over here a
multi-stage water filtration, so we have
extremely pure water
We we provide water here.
So this is incredibly healthy
and there's no particulates
or any plasticizers This is very good
for keeping people hydrated.
Lastly, we provide
a veritable cornucopia of sustenance,
as you can see here.
We are making
Taiwanese
braised pork, rice,
and there's there's food here.
And, you know,
we do a good job of sustaining
our employees to keep them very healthy.
What makes Filtrous different
for for what makes Filtrous different
than most companies?
I would say it's the people.
The people are the best thing
about this place.
Excuse me. Can you can you move?
So the people, especially the employees
and the star employees, are
what makes this place the best.
What effect
has Filtrous had on my personal life?
It has completely overtaken
and overrun my entire life in a good way.
But, you know, it's
like 24/7 Filtrous and.
But I love it.
So it's like 24/7, seven, days a week,
day after day, hour after hour,
night after night.
Just Filtrous, Filtrous
and then I just work and I work.
And then I sleep here.
I'll show you.
You know, I.
I go to bed right here and I sleep,
and that's about as long as I should be
sleeping at night, and I go back to work.
How do I empower my employees
to have a voice
The question should be,
how do I get them to shut up?
It's always like,
David, you know,
where's the where's the milk for my latte?
You forgot the oat milk or, hey,
did you pick up beans at Costco?
Like, where's our where's our beans?
We don't have beans for the expresso
machine or.
Oh, oh,
it's zippy the plants one year anniversary
can we buy a cake for the office?
What is
some advice I would give new employees?
Well, I like to think of myself
as a strong mentor and a coach.
What I would say to them
is, follow your dreams.
Don't give up.
It's not the size of the dog in the fight.
It's the size of the fight and the dog.
And just.
Just do it.
You know
what makes Filtrous
a place people want to work.
I thought that was part of the deal.
I was.
You told me we do this
video and people will want to work here.
But now you're asking me.
That's kind of like me
paying you to have me do your job.
I don't I don't really understand
what's going on here.